dr ashish jaw is with us at the table
this morning he's a dean of brown
university school of public health i
came up to you it's good to see you
because i'm saying you do you have a
bottom half
i'm so used to we're so glad that you're
here at the table
you you always bring a very calm and
reassuring voice so help us unpack all
of this you know i hear many experts
saying we've turned a corner delta's
going down the rates are going down the
end is near do you believe that too well
i do think we've turned the corner
there's no doubt about that in my mind
as i look at the data we still have a
lot of americans getting sick and dying
every day hundred thousand infections
1500 americans dying every day so the
end is not necessarily near it'll get
nearer much faster if people more people
get vaccinated
but i think the worst is behind us we
still have some rocky days ahead rocky
days
go ahead nate no speaking of those
vaccinations um we're hearing about
these kids ages five to 11. how soon
will that happen yeah i'm hoping really
soon i you know i have a nine-year-old
and i'm hoping he's gonna get his first
shot by halloween so
look we're gonna find out in the next
couple of weeks from the fda and my hope
is with that authorization five to 11
year olds should be able to get
vaccinated pretty quickly thereafter you
say we've already turned the corner so
if if these mandates go through for 100
million american workers and younger
children are getting vaccinated with the
quarter turn already plus those two
things where are we when you look ahead
yeah that's what makes me optimistic now
we still have the fall and winter to get
through and especially in the northern
half the country it gets colder people
are spending more time indoors so i we
might see little spikes little little
bumps in cases new england which is very
well vaccinated i think is going to do
okay midwest great plain states a lot of
places with low vaccination rates i'm
more worried how soon can you imagine a
time when we're not wearing masks and
doors and restrictions in most places at
most times are just gone well we're
starting to see it a little bit already
places like san francisco that have very
high vaccination rates they're starting
to already peel back some of those mass
mandates i think that's great
certainly by early next year it all
depends on how good a job we do on
getting people vaccinated kids
vaccinated and adults and it always
boils down to that getting people
vaccinated holidays coming up there's a
lot of friction already in families
do you think it's okay for non and i'm
not taking the kids out of the equation
you think it's okay for vaccinated and
non-vaccinated adults to be together
over the holidays you know gail i hate
to say this i don't think it's great i'm
not doing it i you know the issue is
unvaccinated people especially with
delta out there
are real risks their risks to themselves
they can cause breakthrough infections
in vaccinated people
so i think people just need to get
vaccinated and i think gathering should
be all vaccinated if at all possible we
are exhausted by all of this have we
learned any lessons to plan for future
for things in the future that's a great
question look we're going to have more
pandemics we do not are going to have
more
and we do not want to go through what we
just went through the last 18 months
there's so much we can do and we've got
to get working on preventing
this kind of an outcome i think we can
we know what to do to prevent pandemics
we know what to do to how to manage them
more effectively we got to go get those
things implemented it seems like we do
collectively do you believe the
government is that's the question handle
another oh that's our representatives
well you know what's been really
frustrating to me in this is how much we
have turned this into a political
football yes like we again what do we
know we know that you need to have lots
of testing available we know that you
got to get vaccines developed and people
have to get vaccinated we know that for
a short period of time you have to wear
mass if it's a respiratory virus
these are things that we can do
in the future as long as we don't turn
this into a you know a political
football i think yeah we do know and we
can do it it is a political football
though it is yeah well let's score
touchdowns and not throw interceptions i
love that look at that
i appreciate you always coming with the
valuable information that we need